troy you your whole thing is you're
always recording that's your whole
you've said that to me cbr baby avr
always johnny
is that recent did that just happen so i
mean i look i want to look more as i get
older i was a blonde
my sister found this picture of me and
it's the first picture
where i look at it and go i look like
traveler
and it's like like i i could i could see
it and
i was like platinum blonde like shiny
gold blonde
rumpelstiltskin turned straw uh
all the way up until like i was like
maybe 10 or something like that
and then it started getting like darker
and then i didn't care about it my hair
has been every color of the sun i don't
care
and um of the sun under the sun
every color under the sun the sun is one
color
the sun on the palm of your head yes
well actually i would say arguably the
sun isn't just one that's what i was
going to say is the sun also creates the
aurora borealis
what even is the color hey let's start
as we mean to go on
yeah just the sun color that i think of
when i talk about the sun the same color
as what you think about yellow
that one still blows my mind the uh well
never mind the whole concept of redshift
of
other suns as well right that's
troy did you die you'll go back and look
at the record
that was pre-meditated okay
that was intentional anyway troy you
dyed your hair to look like traveler is
that what your suggestion is because
that's very cute
yeah and um we did we did a little
backyard hang
my friend came out everyone was massed
up and and um
did a little uh she just did this little
jobber and i was like
just kind of can you go for it she was
like what do you mean
i was like just i want something just
different like just go for it she was
like
okay and so she went whack and i was
like
kick ass it's just something different
man i just i get
bored really easily with with this
um so yeah i change it up as often as i
can
for all you audio listeners i was
mentioning to my
johnny bravo alpha form
didn't you say i once upon a time i
think you told me
that once upon a time when you um
were when you first read for the part of
joel
weren't you like full platinum blonde
then
no it was even worse like it was just
like it was
uh a straight-up like backup dancer for
k-pop band it was like
bleached tips kind of thing it was like
whatever it was
opposite to joel yeah you you made me
you made me
feel an enormous amount of um
positive like my impression of
neil and who whoever else was kind of in
the uh
stakeholder position for the casting my
my impression of them rose considerably
that they would look at that
and get it wearing a helmet so i mean
yeah
we can make that we can make that work
yeah
it was yeah i mean i i uh the only role
that i was like
one two almost one to one cast uh was
was snow in in uh final fantasy because
like i had that hair
i had anime hair and i
i liked it and i did it i was gonna say
that miles morales i feel like like
he i could at least recognize as you
base wise not not my likeness somebody
not at all
yeah no but for some reason they did
everybody else and i think maybe i was
brought in
i have no idea but i was like nope we're
getting this guy and i was like okay
it's not gonna be me he's like no i was
like all right damn it
this this makes me leg day was mine
though you might have moved the eyes
around that's how it's often done is
like you'll just tweak the eyes a little
to reflect the actor
even if it's someone else's likeness
we've done that before marker point like
joel
if you look at the difference between
one and two joel looks more like me
and for sure ellie looks more like
ashley they they did that as a one
more more one-to-one so that the
fidelity of was able to we were able to
come a little bit closer to the to the i
remember when we when we cast you in
with
the concept i just went in and literally
had a photo of your eyes
and added your oh there you go really
i can just see it like he's definitely a
little blockier than you hey look
kenneth branagh meets
um why do i have my elbow up so high
when i drink that's
very strange you should put some skull
everybody that's the frame the tattoo
isn't it
there's no way i wouldn't spill this if
i tried to do that
just just just to point out um that was
pain mirroring is a real thing that
human beings do
that's really uncomfortable communities
i do want to point out i guess troy is
the alpha here and we just can't
so if people ever go you're a voice
actor it's like this is preparing for a
new role
wow so you uh we've been getting we've
been getting gnarly
i just those are starting like this from
yesterday looks good i imagine we're not
a lost allowed to ask any questions
about that
you are free to ask anyway we have to
cut all that for nda
no way no one's gonna see it coming
everyone's gonna be like wait
what an elden rings coming out in
december so that's crazy
i'm a changed man for what i just heard
i have a question about your casting or
audition process
actually that you made me think about
because
it's actually not really a joke that
they would be able to look past
how you look and purely listen to the
point of making me wonder i know that
people do self tapes and stuff and i
imagine audio only
is a part of that but because of you
know on a roll like that you know
there's going to be a lot of motion
capture but how do they
is there a process to kind of mitigate
how much your eyes are going to
influence
what you're absorbing even though you
know that
that this character will not look like
this
you know do you get what i'm asking it's
not very well articulated no no i think
i understand i think mike could also
speak to this with a little bit more
i've i've only had to cast a few things
and
it is a it is a it is a
you if you think as an actor it's hard
to audition try being on the other side
and having to cast the role it is
inevitable infinitely harder really or
oh my god yes because
shadow of war right for each role
we were we saw hundreds of submissions
and you're just i mean you're just going
through and the way that they wanted to
cast
was let's listen to the voice first and
then if we like it we'll bring him in
and see how the movement is
so i'm sitting here at my computer and
i'm listening just just having through
and listening to terrible terrible
terrible oh that's interesting
okay let's bring him in are we terrible
or just wrong
for what you want a lot a lot of times
terrible and now that could be
communication was not communicated
effectively to the actor in order for
them to give us the kind of thing that
we were looking for
it could be people just don't know how
to uh audition well and so they're
i think most actors don't know how to
audition they're talking here
like can you get close to the microphone
at all sorts of stuff
um but the audition process in and of
itself is
is just fundamentally flawed uh it
doesn't really provide a lot of
data proper usable actionable data for
for people to make a proper decision on
even when you do an
in-person like you're reading with the
director
that process in and of itself is
fundamentally flawed because it's
predicated
upon so many false things
you don't like if i listen to an
audition i'm like wow that's really good
152 takes compt together in order to
give us the take that it was like that's
good
so i don't know and when the people come
in it's like let's see what you got and
they they come and they do this thing
he's like that's great
there was the thing that judd apatow put
out that was like every actor deserves
two reads
that's judd apatow judd apatow has
infinite more directing experience
that i do and he has a different style
than maybe i do i don't necessarily
believe that's true
because i believe that being direct with
someone and going before you waste any
more time
or before you give me any more of your
time is probably a better way to phrase
that
i want to let you know for this specific
role
um i love what you did but i can't it's
it goes back to what uh
david ball told me uh or sorry alan ball
told me
he's like i can't use it he's gonna say
is that is that the brother no one's
heard of that does the brother don't
want to hear it
um alan baltom's i can't use you what
you're doing is great i got to the
parking lot feeling refreshed going i
don't have to worry anymore about this
so i don't necessarily and if if an
actor comes in and they're not prepared
and they're
too hung up on whatever it is they're
thinking about themselves they're not
thinking about the character
because the character isn't auditioning
the character is just walking into the
room and showing you what they look like
so i don't necessarily believe that you
you inherently
come with an infinite amount of takes or
or even two takes sometimes
if someone was coming in like oh yeah um
get down we're gonna die be like
what i don't know get down you're gonna
die okay thank you that's all i needed
to see from you
i don't think that was like let's go and
do it again it's like no because there's
the person behind you
that is like i cannot wait i know
exactly what this needs i need to get to
them
i need to cast the role i don't need to
make you feel good as an actor but that
also sounds like you're
you're putting a lot of stock into
whatever homework the actor has done
beforehand
and saying like for example in your
emotionally inert read just then of the
of the guy
uh um that was a woman by the way
[Laughter]
well in that case
i uh i like the um
i i wonder if you know
that person is has made that choice and
you're thinking
you know okay this is where they see it
going
and therefore i have plenty other
options that are closer from a starting
position because
how many times have we all been in a
situation where we were making a thing
we threw something against the wall it
was fundamentally not right but then we
iterated there and and and got there so
the audition process
is basically kind of forcing you to skip
all that and just
land really close to the mark basically
auditions for especially in the triple a
space i think make it so difficult
because they won't tell you what the
project is and they'll flip the words
so like you could be playing a villain
uh for
you know a franchise super well known
but they won't tell you that that's what
you're doing so you have to make all
these guesses based on the context that
they've intentionally removed the
scripts are fake for half the auditions
i'm okay with because you guys keep
leaking [ __ ] no [ __ ]
like the second actor is not yours
particularly but actors like we have i
was gonna say mike could be talking to
any number of people
all of that is true that wasn't pointed
at one specific quadrant
um the two that have never intentionally
leaked anything
the uh you have you haven't but many
actors unfortunately that you'll bring
in oh my god tweeting like as they're
leaving the room and it's
infamous the guy that got cast as cold
this the the second call is like what's
up selfie
nope bye you're done i
i don't think that if an actor comes in
first of all there's a lot of factors at
play i love this example there's a lot
of factors that played if an actor comes
in and they gave the emotionally inert
read
was that the first thing they did when
they walked in did they was there a
shift so they could see that that was a
choice
if i was in that situation and i saw
them go hey everybody
my name is john really a pleasure to be
here um i can't wait to show you what i
prepared you have any questions for me
um i have a couple of questions for you
i know that this is kind of like
taking place in xyz country it says xyz
country
um i'm assuming that's probably going to
be maybe something else
asking questions very engaged it's like
great uh john let me see what you got
get down we're gonna die okay so you
made a choice but i could tell that
you're making a choice versus coming in
uh thanks so much for coming in uh is it
john
yes john okay cool uh do you have any
questions for us
no okay um
this is your camera right here where
this person's gonna be reading with you
let me see what you're gonna do get done
yeah that distinction is get out
incredibly clear yeah
yeah so what i'm saying is you can't
have a pat rule that say
i don't believe you can have a pat rule
that says everybody no matter what gets
two tries
there could be someone that comes in and
i've seen this happen before
where they get violent and
someone came in for a game once and they
threw a chair into a wall because they
really wanted to show
how into the role they were and they
were screaming at the reader
that was also the casting director made
her cry
that person doesn't quote deserve a
second take
i can't i followed that person and i
came in and i'm sitting with a casting
director
and she was just like um
just give me a just a minute i uh and i
was like
let's pause and let's
let's just talk are you okay what do you
mean she's like i just don't understand
she broke down
it's like that's she's like i don't
understand how these people are here in
this city
working and they think that that's a
that's the strength the smart choice the
right choice to do
i mean i imagine aren't they actors
there's definitely you definitely do
come across
so i i guess my my approach is actually
a bit different to troy's well not
different i think we're
basically coming at the same thing but i
think it's different different
roads to the same destination i
definitely looking for range like i'm
looking for specifically someone i don't
expect to find a character in that room
and i'm not particularly interested
necessarily in what their take
is at the audition stage like i'm
looking for
a craftsman like i would if i'm looking
at an artist's portfolio i'm not looking
for like in their portfolio
they have a character who could go in my
game tomorrow i'm looking for like
can this person fit and do something
you know that fits what we're doing i
think the same is true of actors i also
cast
without visuals because as a rule for
exactly the reason
that came up like because i'm an idiot
like i'm genuinely going to
make a casting decision based on whose
face i think best looks right for the
character
right i think that's a natural thing
even if you're conscientiously
telling yourself not to do that and
actors know this like i
i was lit i literally spoke to an actor
in the last week who'd auditioned for a
role and that actor had chose a t-shirt
based on the role they thought they were
uh up for like 100
and you see us a lot as well on like um
making right
i think so um the uh the uh
you see this on making off documentaries
a lot where an actor will
um you'll be watching uh scott pilgrim
is a good example of this if you watch
the
like the the making of the the test
footage basically for each actor
the smartest actors who are auditioning
for scott pilgrim are all wearing
nerd property t-shirts their own batman
logos
marvel logos star wars logos because
they're like that's
going to subconsciously influence and
give this impression i'm a nerdy
character for a nerdy franchise and it
works and you see this all the time
you've done that right
it's all [ __ ] no i think it no i
think it works on idiots like me man i
think it works on idiots
i think there's like i think for every
audition you're doing it works
i know i'm influenced by which is why i
do just the audio yeah but
i'm not saying that it's not effective
but i still call [ __ ] on it
because i have been in the room where
i've seen that person get cast because
oh my god look what they just did oh
they're so in love with this
and they're like the take that they gave
me that that's exactly what you're when
you did the auditions exactly what i
want
and you go to shoot it and you go so you
auditioned you were
you were um you're really angry i want
to see what happens when you show some
vulnerability
right well that's stupid yeah you
shouldn't you should check for
everything you need in the audition yeah
right so what i'm saying is it because
it's a manipulation it's it's the the
first audition that i ever did was going
down and doing a pilot
for a an abc show that never got picked
never went to season
and i auditioned next and there's this
other dude the
character's name is martin hanel and the
character was supposed to be a truck
driver it didn't matter his name didn't
matter his occupation didn't matter
the the writer spun the roulette wheel
of character descriptions and chose that
but the guy coming in for the role
wifebeater
coveralls and you could tell right
before he walked in
he stuck his hands on his tires and did
this
that guy didn't get it who got it i did
because i understood something in the
character scene not because i was better
than him
because i was like i looked at the text
so it's just like all this i appreciate
that
but my point my point isn't that that's
a definition that that guy's going to
get the role i'm saying that guy
probably improved his chances
i also feel like if he feels like he is
embodying the character
in a way even for himself it could make
him more comfortable in that role
um i've not had a hand in casting but
i've had a hand in you know
things that have been written that have
been cast and the way that we did it at
rooster teeth internally is a way that
like
i feel like helps when i'm writing stuff
is uh
it's like this character so we're
looking for someone who's
like daria but a little bit more like
this and i feel like that
great analogy you get loads of like
really good auditions because people
have a reference and i feel like i often
write that way too it but which which if
it came to casting would be kind of
difficult where i'm like
this character sounds probably like this
person in this thing
so then when it gets to the process
where i would hear auditions that's kind
of i tell my casting director that i
wouldn't necessarily tell the actor that
no
i would i would use that as a filter for
the casting process
but actors often will come in and
they'll try and do an impression
the other thing i wanted to throw in
just as an additional as well so first
of all yes we are stupid and we do fall
for t-shirts
um and that's why i do audio only
auditions the other reason i do that i
also often will do it
one step removed so i'll have a casting
director handle
a lot of the audition process for me
i'll obviously review the tapes and
everything but i'll let someone else do
that
specifically because i know i'm very
susceptible to human interaction
i will be charmed by someone in the room
or i will
um miss i will i will basically i hear
things wrong in the room
i always you know when you're working
with someone who's coming for an
audition
you're getting to know them they're a
new person you're
reading their facial cues you're reading
their voice you're kind of your brain is
doing everything we do in a social
situation kind of get to know someone to
kind of learn okay who's that
they look a bit like this person i know
so i'm expecting them to behave in this
way or they do something different
and you're kind of you're piecing that
together and i find that incredibly
distracting
because when they do that line read
they're actually they're they're
you know they're performing 20 of what
i'm hearing because i'm also doing all
of that
[ __ ] in my head at the same time so
you're trying to figure out who they are
that's even like a defense mechanism
thing you're supposed to try to be like
who are you and where do you fit into my
knowledge
we're human humans are sociable
creatures and there's a lot of that get
in the way and it has happened to me
where i've
where i've cast someone based on like
thinking they were getting the audition
and then
gone into the recording process and been
like oh i i
just really like you um like i want to
hang out with you and have a drink with
you
but you're not of course that's right
for this yeah you're not saying well
it's not i love daddy
i'm joking i'm here that's great
it's not it's not either let's stop
guessing because there's only so few he
he was robbed of that bafta
um the uh there's there's no there's
there's like there's definitely
um there's definitely that human aspect
to it that's something i try and cut out
um yeah i think i think ultimately it's
it's a really
shitty difficult process um i don't
expect anyone to be doing an audition
because most actors suck at auditions
even the ones who think they're good
let's get into that i'll ask both of you
okay um troy do you have any advice for
people
in auditions where voice acting
specifically is concerned
dude i yes i assumed but like what is it
yeah
um i i just kind of did like a six week
thing about this
um glenn moore shower who was in 24 he's
just one of those guys he's been in
everything
is he the guy who's always um a secure
uh uh secret service guy he's the air
force foremost
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
general moore shower my favorite story
with
with michael bay specifically secret
story i know this one is
um glenn gets get br brought in
the reason why he's worked for michael
bay is because he gets cast
in um uh pearl harbor and
he's general admiral what's its [ __ ] i
don't know whatever his name is that's
it
he shows up and spell he gets okay
f okay he gets his call sheet and it's
admiral what's his [ __ ]
and glenn moore shower he's like crate
and then he looks down and like number
10 on the call sheet is
um insane number two glenn moore shower
and he's like that's weird so he goes to
the second ad he was the person who's in
charge of the call sheet
he goes hey just let you know there's a
little oversight i just want you to be
messed up my name is uh
twice on the call sheet it's you know
admiral what's the [ __ ] and also
incident number two and the second a.d
goes white
and they go i'm terribly sorry there's
been a mistake he's like stop me down
just
you put the wrong name whatever the
wrong goes um
no uh we've we've cast admiral what's
his [ __ ]
and it's whoever he goes
i was cast as admirals we understand
so he was met with the decision do i
raise hell and go uh no you cast me as
this
he goes so my performance of this
was topped only by this i worked for one
day and made more money
comparatively than anything else michael
bay noticed that he was like you're in
every one of my movies and he is
to the point where he goes and does
transformers dies
brilliantly and michael bay calls it
he's like hey i want you to come back
for transformers too and he goes
absolutely no problem
i have one question does it bother you
that i
died in the previous one
michael bay says continuity is for
[ __ ] i'll see you tomorrow
and no one cared no one had a problem
with it because it's absolutely nice
it's that guy anyway you were saying
about him you were talking about
something
um he i i i was gonna say i love how
that that story just
that was the advice troy has to offer
yeah do you have advice
acted video games this is like this is
like
we are five tabs deep at this point so
yeah this to me look at mike proven he
codes
this this
the fundamental thing was this was the
the paradigm shift for me
glenn moore shower does the class and
it's called the extra mile and i got the
benefit of not only having this
seeing his class as he formerly does it
but also getting it
uh very casually offhandedly as we were
shooting a movie that was terrible
but he said i used to play racquetball
every friday
and on the friday before my wedding i
told my buddy i couldn't play
racquetball because he was getting
married and his
in-laws were coming in town he was um
going to finally meet his in-laws so he
didn't say i was going to
audition with my in-laws he said i'm
going to meet
my in-laws i wasn't trying out for the
role of the son-in-law
i was going to show them what their
son-in-law look like
and he says if you go into that meeting
with that he goes the audition is for
the actor
the meeting is for the character and if
an actor goes in and they're nervous
they don't know what to do and it's
um and i'm gonna wear the the wife
beater in the coveralls or the t-shirt
or whatever that is the actor
trying to prove to whomever that they
can act versus
the character just walked into the room
and boy they really got it wrong
but man perfect example ian mcshane in
deadwood was 100
wrong for swearing 100 wrong
but he walked in and he showed milch
what the character looked like
and milch changed the character um that
was going to be a point i raised
actually to ask about this process
because i remember
i felt the same when i hired uh ian
mcshane for a while
okay i was like
he's going to bring something to john
wick
he was oh my god i [ __ ] love that guy
sorry i'm just named
he makes me melt i love it he's amazing
the
uh jack attridge the director of
the game erica when when they were
casting it he
showed me a lot of the actresses uh
reads that and he was like can you help
me with some tiebreakers here you know
there's a handful of really interesting
choices and they were all really
different
and the thing that had him hung up was
that it what was exciting is that
different
different actresses take
opened up this world of possibilities
for different types of people that erica
as a character can be and that was what
made it so compelling because it was
like
this actress she seems
vulnerable like someone i want to
protect and as a game
player playing a game who's you know
controlling her fate as it were
i like the idea that i have this
automatic empathy which is the way this
person carries themselves how they look
etc
this other person this looks like
someone burned by life they've got some
you know there's some there's mileage on
the tires there's old soul in their eyes
this looks like someone who's really
seen some [ __ ] and i really
i i that gives me a different and it was
a it was really interesting to see that
it
the audition process wasn't just we're
trying to find
we have this exactly perfect abstract
notion of the character and we're
finding that person out there that
exemplifies that but actually the
character is a moving target
which is why good actor will bring that
like a good actor i re
i i often will rewrite my scripts once
i've cast them like that's
pretty standard for me like i'll rewrite
based on i still
still remember like having for a day
just every recording i could find of
troy
just playing in the background while i
just got into his speech patterns for um
for john wick again
interesting something exactly
because it brings something to it really
does if you write for an actor rather
than for a character at that point
but you have to easier to direct them
yeah
it's a whole lot easier to direct that
way too but
what you hit on austin specifically is
very good for actors to hear
because the position of i got to get
this job i need this job i want to get
this job
david meltz the eggs that you sees of
the artist situation are always of the
financial it's always how do i make
money at this
that's the that's the progenitor for
this thing is i want to be able to do
this forever and the only way that i can
do that is by able to be
pay my bills with this thing
but the second that it becomes about i
gotta have this job
i've i've been in that that situation
where i walked in and troy baker was
squarely in that room and troy baker was
in that role and troy baker needed that
job and troy baker was fearful that he
wasn't going to get it
and i told the character to wait in the
hall
you made a comment to uh rahul at the
dice awards
that was i think he was talking about
accent stuff
and you made a comment that was like but
the character's not insecure about their
accent
you are and even as someone who's never
had any fear
with with accents where performances are
concerned i was like that is so
like such a good way to tell someone how
to like let that go because that's not
what you're playing you're not playing
someone who's worried about doing their
accent correctly
you're just playing a character like
it's it's such a it was such a smart
way to to give that advice i was it's
it's advice that was given to me
and i had the same the the light that
not only came on in his mind with that
but the lightness of his being
he was like because he was he was bogged
by that i mean
the thing that i really respect
one of the things i respect about rahul
is is the fact that he is a
every director wants to work with an
actor like him who is so devoted
so committed and like he he
loves the minutia he loves digging into
it
too i mean i could see him getting
really obsessed about it and
in that specific moment i don't know if
that's his the way that he normally
works
he was he was weighed down by this and i
was like brother let me liberate you
from that
here's the switch flip it don't worry
about it i don't think about
i need to make sure i say it in this way
it's just be that person there
don't be the person that or be the
person that has that accent don't be a
person trying to have that accent
because i feel like even in the audition
process
which i don't think that conversation
was in reference to but it would be
when you're auditioning they're probably
going to notice you being insecure and
wrong for the character even more than
an accent being incorrect and you can
get dialect coaching people can pay
for sure it's easier to fix the accent
later than to fix the insecurity coming
through the performance in that audition
yeah and that's that's my point is like
don't you i need to tell myself the way
to the hall i'll be there in a minute
right now the character needs to show up
and the fear comes from what if i don't
get this job
but if you can liberate once i liberated
myself from that is like doesn't matter
if i get this job
then i become a partner of that team and
exactly what austin's talking about
happens like
i just lost a job not didn't i'm sorry
man
literally something that i read today is
like it's correcting the way that i
think
i didn't lose anything i didn't have
something
and so what i thought i was going to get
i didn't get but what happened in the
process
is exactly what austin's talking about
what mike's talking about it's like i'm
able to rethink the character
you showed me a strong version of this
and actually the character needs to be
weak
i'm not worried because i'll work with
those people sometime
but they go thank you i solved their
problem that they didn't even know they
had
the other i wanted to solve one problem
which is to cast that character
but that's not the problem they needed
my help solving somebody else is going
to solve that
problem the problem that i solved was
showing that the character needed to be
this
and not this so that to me if
an actor can go in with that mentality
is i'm here to serve
i'm here to solve the problem i'm here
to be a partner it doesn't
matter if you get the job or not the
goal
is never to get the job that can never
ever ever ever ever ever ever be the
goal it's not to get the job the job
is or the goal is to do the work the job
is not the goal the work is
if you do the work you could get the job
but if you only try to get the job and
you don't do the work
what [ __ ] job is that
do the work and the job will worry about
itself so the advice is focus on
bringing the character to life don't
focus on getting hired
it's not about you yeah trying to
outsmart the casting entities
to know what they're looking for from
you as opposed to
how to help them tell their story
disagreement baby
no i don't think anything you're saying
is not right
i think it's actually pointing back to
something you said earlier which i think
is a
is crucially important is and this is
true
i guess it's just good job interview
etiquette anyway generally anyone
anyone listening to this any profession
you know is gonna is gonna
need to think about this i'm i yes i'm
yes i'm casting the role but i'm also
casting you and yeah i want an actor
who's gonna be a collaborator in the way
you're describing
ultimately honestly more like honestly
like i more than anything else we talked
about
i want someone who's gonna walk into the
room and and make me comfortable make me
feel like i'm going to collaborate well
with this person
i've i've definitely um worked with
people
like i was i'm not sure there are like
genuinely
a studio recently asked me to do
something that would be akin to a
lead and my first reaction was i don't
think i should do this i think that you
should give this to
someone whose job it is i don't i don't
like i'm happy to keep doing cameos but
i was like i don't know that i should do
this and they were like we really want
you to do it
i was like i don't even know if i have
the experience for it it was an ongoing
conversation but then i ended
up being like if i can have an input on
the character like even in the in
a writing perspective then i would love
to do it um but if it's just me coming
into act elite i think you should choose
someone who is a voice actor i don't
want to take that walk away from them
so then basically what i asked for was
narrative input and they were like we're
okay with it
but i feel like a lot of people would
think that's too much no
no you can always ask you don't want to
like like there's definitely so so again
like as a
creative director across a project this
comes up for me a lot because i work
with a
big big-ish team and everyone has kind
of uh opinions and
you know often opinions in areas which
are not what they were hired for right
like
an artist will feel that the game design
sucks on an area or whatever
the the john always has an opinion on
music every member of the team
always wants to weigh in on score god
bless them and they should and i think i
think ultimately
um the reaction when someone comes to
you with stuff like that from a director
should always or
anyone who's a boss should always be a
you know listening to it
interested in it talking to the person
about it
ultimately i think if a director or a
boss is
upset by you bringing up a suggestion or
having a critique
that speaks to their own immaturity and
lack of confidence
that they're threatened by you in that
situation
um but it but yeah a lot of the time a
boss's job is to say
no we're gonna let the composer work out
what the music for this game should be
to use austin's example
but you know often what will happen is
you'll have um
someone on the team who's who's gonna
take and i keep wanting to use specific
examples
but it would be incredibly unfair to my
team but like someone will come to me
and say
i think this this this and this and
there will be good [ __ ] in there and if
i create an environment for my team
where they didn't feel they could come
to me with that [ __ ] i would have missed
out on brilliant ideas that will make
you know and ultimately that's better so
so i think i think
i think you should absolutely feel
comfortable i don't think you should
show up to an audition with notes on the
script and how to change it i think you
should
as and it goes back to professionalism
it goes back to what you're saying kind
of
in a conversation that can continue and
you can kind of
bounce things off each other and
sometimes you'll encounter people
who uh who get frustrated or offended by
that
and if your primary objective is to get
the job uh in troy's words then yeah
you're gonna get that job but maybe it
shouldn't be to get that job because if
it's to work with a director who's gonna
feel
so self-conscious of something that or a
writer that's so self-conscious of their
work that they won't
allow a collaboration then you maybe
don't want that job maybe that's
something you don't want to be stuck
with yeah you don't be stuck with them
for weeks work on something
free preach oh cool yeah that so so yeah
i think i think that's the right call
for you to make but i do think yeah
there is a certain degree of kind of
knowing when to choose your battles and
the politics of that stuff and kind of
when to you know my team might there
there's there's definitely times where
like someone's cut someone from my team
has come to me with an idea at like
5 p.m on a friday and like really
challenge something in the game i'm like
do you see that do you see that i've
poured my mind
i'm like i love the energy bring this to
me on like
tuesday at 11 a.m and let's have a
conversation like there's definitely
like
politics and managing upwards that's
involved in all these things but yeah if
you if you
if you feel that that opening's there i
don't see a problem with it i'd
certainly welcome that kind of
collaboration i've had that before
with um with actors where they've
brought
to actually you know speak honestly
about danny wallace like he definitely
brought ad libbing to thomas was alone
in volume
because he's a comedy writer he had a
take on things he could do with that
script
so there were moments that he had lived
and we recorded all of it and
50 of it didn't work for the game 50 of
it did
the player's better off i'm better off
you know it's all it's all
good because because he had that opening
to kind of do his thing a little bit and
i always try and foster that i do think
that
um i just got held up by danny wallace
your wallet was taken or what no like i
had that i had a point and then i just
thought i i was thinking about thomas is
alone and how good did he was
so good i i think that i i was going to
say
um i approached the desire was pure
but i would come in
especially to like um second son
and i had ideas and i think i may have
shared this story before but i really
owe a lot to brian fleming
um at sucker punch because he was the
first person
i can think of that was like hey let's
post mortem
and okay it's like so i went up to
seattle and he took me out for
biscuits and he was like hey i wanted
your
thing to mike and i it does they were
big great
to me it sounds like he's walking you
with the leader of getting you uh
getting you some little dog biscuits you
get two
and it's a meal it was just like it's
this famous place in seattle he's like
i'm gonna take you the best sausage you
like
biscuits and gravy i was like i was born
in texas sir what do you think he's like
the best was like i don't think so and
they were the best biscuits in the grave
i've ever had
i still asked brian about that place
what's that place called and he'll tell
me i forget
you google it and it never you didn't
talk exclusively about the biscuits in
the post
best pizza i ever had was in japan i
didn't expect that
do you remember moshi burgers yeah oh my
god i've craved those still to this day
there's a there's a pausing your story
troy
down the street from here is a famous
cuban bakery called porto's that's very
like legendary throughout l.a
it's the best right and so years ago
like 2010 or so
i was uh mixing a film and the director
was a
true blood new yorker just like he was
just
as purely new yorker in all of his
mannerisms and everything about him
brilliant brilliant brilliant director
and um
he had come in from new york to do the
dub and we were across the street from
porto's and he was like there any good
uh sandwich places around here and i
said dude
the best pastrami sandwich at porto's i
said knowing where you're coming from
and he said i'm insulted that you would
want to send me knowing what you know
about me
to a cuban place to get a pastrami in
los
angeles he was like go [ __ ] yourself you
find you find me a better option i dare
you sir
look in here yeah yeah yeah
so that so then it was like oh well you
know there's plenty other choices
whatever blah blah
the next day we're back at the dub stage
and he goes so i have a confession
he was like after all that i snuck over
there right before they closed and that
was
for [ __ ] sake one of the best pastrami
sandwiches i've ever had in my life it
was so good i'm now going to like
rabbinical school like it
it it like reconfirmed my beliefs
this episode of play watch listen is
sponsored by podos
shout out i so brian fleming takes me
out first for biscuits and i've eaten
there that's
right first day for our first rich food
i love you
guys to sit in this podcast i just like
i just like to exist in this podcast
occasionally and that was a wonderful
moment
as we were like three diversions deep it
was just wonderful
what i'm here for the possible the first
point so we're saying he goes uh
or they're you're an extended part of
our team i'd like to know is there
anything that we could have done better
and i told him
and i was like yeah man here we go they
tell you how to make your
aaa game better and he goes great is it
are you open to the same
i was like absolutely bro bring it on
and he said
you're expecting him to be like maybe
let next time be
less handsome be less perfect you're
that what you
it was tiring working with you because
you exercised
my skills so greatly yes you we could
not reach the bar that you set for us
i thought i knew who this character was
until i met you
so brian goes and brian's just such a no
[ __ ] guy
and he goes uh you're a very powerful
force i was like thank you guys it's not
a compliment
um he said you where you're trying to
enact
change is too far down the river
and i went what he said you have great
ideas
but you have an idea and the that the
pages that we hand to you
have blood on them the battles have
already been fought
and i went i didn't realize that
i was trying to be a collaborative
partner i was trying to be
a problem solver i was trying to help
because i wanted to be
helpful and what i didn't realize is
that what i needed to be
was not a general but a soldier and i
needed to find the best way to execute
i love that that quote by richard burton
was like even if it's rubbish be the
best rubbish in it and second son was by
no means rubbish
but the understanding is like it's not
my job to make this thing better
it's my job to be the best that i can be
well the truth is well yeah but a lot of
the writing suggestions have probably
already been conversations that have
been had in writer's rooms and the
decisions have already been made
sure but it doesn't hurt it doesn't hurt
the writer to hear that
again like i i definitely i definitely
have that conversation i
i at an earlier point in my directing
career i definitely told people
can you just can you just do the thing
because we've had the arguments already
and that's been
those are the moments i regret most like
because that that cuts someone out the
conversation you do
i do try the number of times i have to
re-explain something that
like you say the blood on the page is
already on the page but like that
doesn't mean we can't do an autopsy in
the room that's fine
but the the difference what i'm saying
is that the the effect and the impact
can be the same but if i go in going
let me show you how you can do this
better versus i'm gonna be the best that
i can be
and if i give the absolute best that i
could possibly be and it's still
[ __ ] then maybe the writer goes man
that's just not working
versus me telling him it's not working
and now he's got a defensive position
so i want to be the best that i can be
because then i'm
always helping i'm always solving the
trying to at least solve the problem
and we can still shine a light on the
fact that the problem is not getting
solved
without me going you guys should solve
that problem that's that's oppositional
and adversarial
i think that well especially if you have
people that are
punishment though in fairness i think
well i think it's also contextual right
like your games probably
are more flexible later into the process
than something where they're booking 20
days of mocap
and right and you know there's a [ __ ]
ton of
moving parts i think they're less
flexible at that stage
the decision well no you're right but
but there's
it all is also a decision like a certain
amount of
[ __ ] to be eaten is something that every
director has to decide like how much am
i going to put up with this person's
[ __ ] is like a part of the process
right
because but you kind of want to
encourage that because they'll say some
gold in there or
and you know it depends obviously by
person like some people will say a lot
of nonsense and then there'll be a gold
nugget
some people are very bad at presenting
good ideas like you'll have to listen to
them
really be bad and they'll come across as
arrogant they'll they'll be
argumentative they'll blah blah blah
but the stuff they're saying is so good
that you're still a fool if you don't
listen to it you know what i mean it's
kind of
that takes a real talent by the way to
if someone's being
active very
to begrudgingly admit to someone having
a good idea and to hearing it
through your active filter that's saying
god i just hate you so much
it to me that's a real thing i don't
tell anyone i work with to be honest
like i
i i worked with well you know what i
mean last summer i worked with a
a great director who by his own right
to be able to tell anybody to go [ __ ]
off like he
he's earned the accolades of the
position and it was steven spielberg
steven spielberg stephen um i call him
spielsies but
um reportedly one of the absolute nicest
people to work with by the way
shows that there's a team that's very
happy around him like it feels
spielberg films feel like things made by
company he directs directors and he says
the best he has every time i walk out on
the set even to this day i have no idea
what i'm doing
what makes me a good director is that
nobody knows that i'm like
dude that is absolutely it i that this
director that i worked with
um i watched this he took notes from
everybody
and he's like cool try that it's great
and i was like
you have the right you can say what
everyone is like yeah it's creative
darwinism man best idea wins
maybe i have it maybe i don't i don't
care and i finally realized towards it
we shot for like two weeks and finally
by the end of it i was like i get it
you just love to shoot he goes i love to
shoot as long as they'd let me [ __ ] i'll
shoot i was like
man way to be single-minded and focused
do i get to keep doing the thing i love
do i get to get
and this is he's done so much and he can
be like i don't have to put up with it
do you know what i've done i don't
put up with this [ __ ] and he's just
like i'll just love to shoot i just love
to shoot
where show where the camera is i want to
shoot it you want to do that [ __ ] do
that
dancing bears awesome bring them in
let's do it that's the way that i want
to
assume that's what you were cast as i
was yeah
is also please stop giving me these
opportunities to name john he's also a
lovely player
the the um the the what's gonna say the
um
yeah no one benefits more from a good
idea than the director ultimately
like like and any way you can get a good
idea it's worth listening
to find that good idea because because
you otherwise you have to come up with
everything on your own
and that will drive you mad so it's not
even a selfless act it's it's just
being open to good ideas wherever they
come from the short film i made
me looking clever i i had aggressively
shot listed like i was like this looks
like this and there were a few of those
shots that i was like these can't change
these things have to be this exact way
but then sean who's the cinematographer
also shot some stuff that i had no
intention of including that because he
as a cinematographer just has an eye for
making things look pretty and i was like
i don't need this shot necessarily
narratively but you shot that so pretty
wait do
but that was just sorry he was [ __ ]
gorgeous like what
what the way he shot it was great yeah
uh but that yeah there was shots in
there that i had very cinematic for a
very uh
intimate uh concept which is i love that
i have to also give you props there's
there's three things that an actor can
always
look it's so easy for an actor to look
fake doing
yawning uh sneezing
and sleeping and to start out of the
gate
with a sleeping shot great very stephen
typical by the way you're not supposed
to ever start a short film with the
alarm clock going off but i committed to
having to do it [ __ ]
or uh uh so snow white and the seven
dwarfs the greatest animation ever
created them
because they got one you've got sneezing
you got sleepy got yawning
but in any case it was super fun to be
collaborative and use stuff that sean
shot that like was not my intent at all
um that just like made the whole thing
better in any case
like even though some of my shots were
really specific and i was like it has to
be exactly this way i must be sitting on
the balcony and the city must be in the
background and i know that you as a
cinematographer want to shoot over my
shoulder and have me eating from this
perspective and i was like
even if it sounds stupid it doesn't work
that way but it was really it was really
fun to do
and i think was there ever something you
had you were like
here's something that because i've been
in this situation before even directing
where it's like
it has to be this and someone goes i'm
going to shoot it that way i'm going to
show you
and you go [ __ ] it doesn't look the way
that i want
or a lot of times i was like i just want
camera to move from here to here they're
like
okay um do you i out of my ignorance
i didn't understand camera language if
you move right to left that says
something
like the moving camera from right to
left is
that not the way that we read so
therefore it will subconsciously make
people feel
uneasy it can help be used to help
communicate
someone's off they're doing something
wrong versus tracking left or right
so a lot of times i just i don't know
it's left or right or right to left
they're like i'm going to show you but i
was curious if in that process there was
anything you're like it has to be this
and then you sought you're like oh
that's not what i want there are shots
that i took out
but it was mostly to do with lighting
where the
light was wrong for the transition of
events that i was trying to tell um
the one thing that he pointed out that i
had no idea of
which we didn't end up using um but is a
thing that i like i just didn't occur to
me was
my head having studied pieces of
photography
as part of my journalism degree was that
you never cut someone's head off
and he was like they do it in film all
the time it doesn't matter and i was
like how does that not matter
but then some of the stuff we shot where
like maybe i would be cut like here
it actually doesn't it's very frequent
in film and it's a thing that my brain
is like no no you can't do that that's
absurd that's
you could never do that but it's it's
happens all the time and now i notice it
all
right zack snyder four by three
director's cut
it's also the difference i'm sorry
that's the difference between also
between stills and video
like it's the same reason in photography
you would never cut off someone's feet
right um it's there's limit there's
less information that you're presenting
in a still
or in in in still yeah than you are film
you've got
24 frames happening a second not 250th
of a second
so it's it's like there's there's a lot
more information you can convey
like selling a story if someone's here
like the difference the reason why
close-ups and stuff
are are different they convey different
things a still is a single image so
photography to me is totally different
i think that this exemplifies what you
just said though alana is something that
was actually
in my head based on what you were saying
troy about your
dp saying you know the difference of
right to left versus left to right and
that kind of thing
i have a tendency my knee jerk is to
bristle at a comment like that
because it can be very difficult to suss
out the difference of this is somebody
who's a pro
who's experienced who is saying
just trust me you're not going to like
it versus somebody who has fallen into
this sort of formulaic
well look if that's you know if it's a
dutch angle it means this and then
they've got this yeah these are the
rules this is how it's done
and it's like but the art this is
terrifying so this is how it's done i
agree
[Music]
i had this exact same kind of
conversation with the this kind of [ __ ]
happens to comp
sorry one second because this [ __ ]
happens with composers all the time
with the form of like the way it
manifests for us at least is
you know oh don't this is this is not a
sentimental thing i don't want
violin or this is not futuristic so
don't
do you know 80s analog synths or it's
like
it's it's people codify certain things
to such a degree that they're like oh
it's not that kind of
my favorite was my my buddy jason graves
who did the um
the dead space games when when the team
was that was making that
psvr game moss initially was looking for
composers
uh his agent uh said uh have you talked
have you
thought about jason and because of the
association with dead space they go oh
it's not that kind of game
uh which was there of course he ended up
getting the job which was
fantastic but anyway continue trying
allow me to respond yeah
there there's you are allowed one of my
i had this conversation with my
guitarist and and the band that i was in
once and i was like
i wanted to go from here you can't do
that
because musically from a theory
perspective in the circle of fifths
you're actually
breaking that rule so lame so i was like
well that's also jazz
right jazz is all about breaking the
rules my favorite quote from daniel
lanois
is it's not about breaking the rules
it's about ignoring them
because i have a different favorite
david wahl
all right i think i'm joking
the different one that i have is i'll
have the pancakes please uh daniel
lanois
is is what he's positing or at least the
notion is
it's not you can break the rules and not
ignore them i'm so sorry officer i
didn't know that that was the speed
limit here
there's a difference between saying that
and going i understand what the rules
are
then i'm going to intentionally ignore
them
so i i love that but the difference
about especially camera language though
you have to acknowledge that they're not
even rules to begin with like baked into
the premise of your statement is that
they are that's exactly where i'm going
with this
wild one in writing just real quick
that's do you know what a widow is
so i've encountered this in more than
one writer's room and i always find it
very funny but like i'm like hey
respect but this is ridiculous and we
should all acknowledge that this is
ridiculous a widow is basically when
you've got a paragraph
but you've written enough that there is
like one or two words that are on the
final line
and even when it comes to a script some
people will intentionally
cut words from their script to get rid
of the widow
understood
interesting okay all writing ones it's
widows orphans it's all like
victorian melons everybody but like they
will literally try to change and
like i'm like it's an aesthetic choice
people think it like looks messy and it
ruins their creative flow or whatever
but even if it's for dialogue people
will cut their whistles
stupid because they think it's true it's
true in graphic design like if i'm doing
a documentary
i'll lay it out to avoid sure the thing
about camera
specifically is like hey man we don't
know why but we just know that if you
have this angle
this is what that that this is how the
audience interprets that now if you want
to ignore that
that's great or if you want to juxtapose
that if you go low angle on somebody
that we get a sense of heroism from that
specific thing it's not nyu film school
teaches that low angle
is this it's something that we notice
that we inherently view people if we
look
up to them there's automatically a
feeling of veneration
versus a a high angle is someone being
oppressed or coming down it says this is
we learned this language we didn't just
create it we observed it
so if you want to change that and like
you take a show like mr robot
mr robot intentionally ignored a lot of
those rules
and presented a hero from from a high
angle or presented a villain from a low
angle
to juxtapose those things i think you
can ignore the rules all the time
but i what i was coming from was a
position of ignorance
to where i didn't speak the i didn't
speak the language
but i had a specific intent and i had a
great dp that was like
i'm going to show i'm going to do that
i'm going to show it to you and do you
see as like it doesn't feel right it's
like
because you're moving from right to left
what you wanted and i even watched this
director almost said his name i watched
this director do that he was like
we're doing this the [ __ ] we can't do
that
change the camera it was like why he
goes left or right and i went
you still adhered to those rules he was
like it's not it's not a rule
it's it's something that you have to
understand that this is the way we
receive information
so it's to me i i look at the widow and
go if that helps you understand
my my text better so be it but i don't
think that i should be like well i'm
going to cut out those two words it's
like
how important are those two words are
they articles
but david milch again with the short
film
again it's like you know the other two
that i've written that i intend to film
this year way more complicated it was a
great one to start on because i was like
i know exactly what these shots are
there's no character it's very simple
just just an expression of isolation
um but the one thing that i was very
very very specific was shown about
before even going in was framing me
within frames it was like if there's a
door frame
i'm placed right in the door frame if if
the you know like the the shot on the
balcony was make sure i am sitting
inside of this shot like if there is
something that you can frame me within a
frame like that is the thing that i
really specifically wanted and
the reason that i wanted that is not
because i've studied film in that
capacity it's actually because of
hereditary which is one of my favorite
movies
and i've spent time watching that movie
and trying to figure out how this
you know family drama that is also in uh
cultish
horror um has shots within a house where
people look extremely oppressed i was
like
um is that the midsomar director yeah
um how do you have a shot in a nice
house where someone looks
extremely oppressed in any case and i
just like tried to figure out how that
happened in that movie and realized it
was all about door frames
it was all about multiple things
surrounding someone and then making them
seem
very far out in comparison and i think
we could have probably accelerated that
but it was a really fun thing to play
with and the only kind of
rule that i was like any opportunity to
have a frame within a frame
we will do that it was fun to do
i i love all those things and to me one
of the beauties of
what the difference between film and
games
is that finally finally this is real
trying to figure it out
is the fact that film is you can scout a
location
and maybe you could build a location but
you simply don't have the same amount of
control that you do
in a game and it affords us more
opportunities to not only
adhere to those rules or it allows us
more opportunities
to find out what happens when we ignore
those rules
to an incredible capacity that's why i
specifically love working
within games it's not that i don't want
to do tv and film because i do
but what i can do inside of the game
space the role
going back to the very beginning the
roles that i'm offered the roles that i
get to play inside the game space
typically i would not be able to do in
the tv or film space
so i'm grateful for the opportunities
that this specific
industry has has afforded me to get to
play medium is awesome
we do very cool stuff games are great
pretty cool
great when you start medium i was first
thinking for some reason like great like
a smart like
i was like i guess that scales yeah
that's kind of true yeah our suck is
still good
the um when i was very first at the
beginning of this asking about that
audition process
part of part of what i was asking about
if you like to to mike to your point of
of you know i i will
my brain will indulge in all of these
extraneous details and i'll
i'll be influenced by it the trivia from
my world that relates directly to that
is that the classical orchestra
world is very it obviously
still has plenty of hallmarks of elitism
and and
uh exclusive tendencies but was famously
very very very
just openly misogynistic for a long time
and women were having a long
uh it was a long struggle to make
headway in getting
jobs within orchestras and then they
instituted a policy in
around the 1970s where all auditions
happened behind a screen
where you would hear the person play and
overnight orchestras started balancing
out at 50 50
because they realized when they can't
look at the person because they would
say
they would of course have these
arguments that sound very reasonable of
oh well you know we looked
we want to hire more women it's just of
the people
these were the best performers and as
soon as you took their eyes
out of the equation to inform that it
turned out that was all self-delusion
and that they were actually just pretty
misogynistic
we are not subjective humans are biased
and we are not objects it has to be an
active you can't just say you want to do
things you actually have to actively
fight those biases i agree you can even
feel like you're not to check your own
biases like that's the thing
i'm like constantly like could be like i
don't know sometimes like
i'm a human so i don't know that's why
discourse is important that's why
dissension is important
is to be able to constantly bump up
against it's not about the negation
it's about inviting those things in
because that's how we move forward
that's how i will become a better person
is when someone goes hey man you're
wrong
brian fleming's setting me down and
going you're a powerful force and that's
not a compliment
it was one of the best moments but i
needed i needed to hear criticism
i needed to hear something that didn't
give you biscuits and gravy food
give me biscuits and gravy when you do
it yeah while it does seem like a great
note to end on
i do want to circle back and ask
questions are you going to pull it off
the show right we do i want to ask you
mike the question
uh what are you doing before you do that
or yeah let's let's
dig in get out of here austin i'm just
gonna mute my mic
what's it what are you asking mike
bithell what what uh what are your tips
for people
auditioning for voice acting roles where
the auditioner
or the auditionee like the person doing
the audition person
doing the auditioning i'd actually like
to hear both frankly
correct i'd like to hear your advice for
for game directors as well
in how to effectively cast austin okay
one step at a time
did i ever tell you how this you always
do this no so mike
famously okay vice advice for the actors
honestly is what i said earlier is is is
i'm call i'm i'm bringing you in as a
collaborator show
so it's much more important to me that
you seem like someone i could work with
to find the character
rather than that you how do you show
that by submitting an audio clip though
so when it's making an audio clip i'm
looking for range
i'm looking for um let's be honest
specifically range usually so with with
when i'm doing
vo so when i'm doing vo that god this is
the thing there's so many different
forms of audition right
when i'm doing uh when i'm auditioning
voice actors one i might be looking at
real
that's often how it works in which case
you don't know what i'm looking for so
just show me everything you can do and
and we'll see
um i'll usually though do a voice voice
audition so that will be you go into a
room with a casting director
and they'll give you some kind of brief
maybe a bit of script like like you said
on like a script of the names changed
and stuff
um and they'll give you some direction
but crucially their showcase range
rather than
a specific take so show me in a
different set of ways
um often as well i'll just cast based on
previous roles so in terms of
specifically the audition process
range range is the thing i'm looking for
range and an ability to listen to
feedback and direction
so i can you do a take i tell you hey i
think let's try this
often i'll give direction an audition
that doesn't actually align with what
necessarily i even want to do
it's more just to test the barriers
that's only only to a point because at
the end of the day i don't need you to
be a swiss army i don't
need you to be able to do things i don't
need but like i i am
testing the edges of your skill set
basically a lot of the time
in that audition process in terms of the
person doing the auditioning i would say
you can speed things along by actually
bringing in a an actual experience
casting director and and
voice performance director i i saw my
career was a bit egotistical about that
and i specifically didn't want to bring
in someone else to do those jobs i
wanted to do it myself
and it meant that i had to kind of
heavily learn that stuff very quickly
through
messing up basically which is which
wasn't fun for me i'm sure wasn't fun
for the actors
so like so like i think there's there's
also a lot of room to bring in those
kind of people and as in all things with
indie development
uh people will do you favors they'll be
cheaper than you think they are
they'll want to work with you to get to
know you for future projects as well so
you can often find people who will be
willing to help who have experience
um and i think that's often being being
in that kind of learning position in
that first
for the first few auditions in the first
few recordings is probably
something that if i could go back i
think i could accelerate my skill set a
little bit by
by getting someone to show me at the
start rather than what i've done which
is kind of muddled my way through to how
i work now
um kind of self-taught but that does
take longer um
to add on to that if i may mike i would
always say this
good advice that was given to me by my
first agent is be the one they want to
call not the one they have to call
yeah and that's that's what that's like
yeah i want to write something for troy
i want to create something because i
like working and i have those mentalists
right as a director there are actors who
i have been
dying to work with for years and the
second i can
like that that's the thing like and it's
and or someone who yeah i say like i've
had a good time working with like you
know there are actors who i've worked
with where i am
my god the first chance i get i'll put
them in something just to kind of get to
work with them again
they're actors who i won't work with
again you know and there's there's
everything in between
so yeah the minute that i get matt berry
in a video game
my work here is done okay
when you can get us we can do it that
was terrible
to be honest that was all yeah but i
knew what you were going for
fire the new clear weapons because it's
me
so good anyway hi everyone this is play
watch list and i'm alana pierce that's
troy baker that's mike biffle
and that's austin wintery um
anyone have any closing thoughts or did
we do it
[ __ ] did it y'all i did it we'll see
you guys next week